[Aplausos]
india 1973 un grupo de mujeres
campesinas se abrazó a 300 fresnos e
impidió que la industria maderera los
talara son las mujeres chico a día de
hoy siguen salvando bosques eeuu 1980
las amas de casa del barrio de love
canal se organizaron para denunciar la
contaminación química que afectaba la
salud de sus familias al final
consiguieron que se proclamará una ley
de responsabilidad ambiental contra los
responsables de esos vertidos inglaterra
1983 70.000 mujeres formaron una cadena
humana de 23 kilómetros para protestar
contra los misiles nucleares
estadounidenses alojados en suelo inglés
llegaron a estar acampadas en la base
militar de green hand como 20 años hasta
que consiguieron que se marcharán estos
hechos tienen en común que están
protagonizados por mujeres que defienden
el medio ambiente y la vida de forma
pacífica que son movilizaciones que no
podemos leer en los libros de texto y
que tampoco tuvieron mucho eco en los
medios de comunicación son prácticamente
invisibles
yo las conocí gracias a mi profesión el
periodismo un oficio en donde tenemos un
problema de discriminación casi el 70%
de los puestos de responsabilidad están
ocupados por hombres
esto junto con otros factores hace que
se genere una agresiva dinámica de
competitividad empresarial donde importa
más el lucro que la calidad informativa
a mí esto me hizo buscar y crear lugares
donde si puedo practicar un periodismo
reposado y socialmente útil hoy quiero
hablaros de comunicación eco feminista y
diréis qué es eso del ecofeminismo
pues es una corriente de pensamiento que
nos recuerda que dependemos de otras
personas y del planeta para sobrevivir
es decir que la especie humana somos
interdependientes y eco dependientes me
explico
en primer lugar interdependientes
dependemos de otras personas porque como
especie somos vulnerables cuando nacemos
necesitamos a nuestra madre para
alimentarnos y protegernos cuando
envejecemos o enfermamos también
necesitamos a otras personas para que
nos cuiden
ese trabajo de cuidar lo realizamos más
las mujeres que los hombres y no porque
nosotras estemos mejor preparadas para
ello sino porque ese trabajo de cuidar
lo infravaloramos culturalmente ni
siquiera remuneramos a pesar de que es
imprescindible para la vida
en segundo lugar e codependientes
dependemos de la tierra porque todo lo
material que necesitamos para vivir nos
lo da la naturaleza el alimento la
vestimenta los medicamentos la energía
el agua a pesar de que nuestra vida está
ligada a los ciclos naturales de los
ecosistemas el impacto que nuestro
sistema económico tiene sobre el medio
ambiente no nos importa demasiado
mujeres y medioambiente vamos a ver
en qué ocasiones estas dos áreas ocupan
un espacio informativo y de qué manera
lo hacen
el pasado 8 de marzo día internacional
de la mujer la multitudinaria
manifestación de aquel día supuso un
antes y un después en el auge del
movimiento feminista y en los medios de
comunicación reportajes sobre
desigualdad de género impactantes
imágenes de las calles repletas de gente
incluso cabeceras de periódicos violetas
dos días después el 10 de marzo volvemos
a la realidad y zasca nos encontramos
con esta noticia en un periódico de
tirada nacional
detenido por matar a su mujer delante de
su hijo en estepona
es posible que a primera vista no veáis
ningún problema en este titular pero lo
hay
el periodista jerarquiza la información
lo que ubica primero es más importante
que lo segundo y esta noticia está
diciendo que el hecho noticioso es la
detención de un hombre este año de
acuerdo
en esto del periodismo hay muchísimas
reglas pero la más importante es los
muertos primero
vamos a ver el titular de otro medio
sobre el mismo hecho fuera una mujer en
estepona a manos de su marido
muere
la herramienta más importante de una
persona que se dedica al periodismo es
la palabra hay que conocer toda la
amplitud de intención y significado que
hay detrás de cada letra muerte y
asesinato son cosas distintas
fallecer es un hecho natural ser
asesinadas significa que alguien te
arrebata la vida
usar la palabra fallecer o morir suaviza
el acto y culpabilizar a la víctima en
esta noticia la mujer no ha muerto ha
sido asesinada
punto
en las redes sociales se empiezan a
criticar estos titulares os pongo el
ejemplo del tuit de las comunicadoras
paramos una red que aúna a más de 2.000
profesionales del sector dicen dejar de
insultar ya mismo la memoria de las
mujeres asesinadas os lo decimos
despacito que vemos que os cuesta
asesinada y asesinato salimos a las
calles a reclamar periodismo feminista y
no vamos a parar hasta lograrlo
unos minutos después también el titular
asesinan a una mujer apuñalada por su
marido en presencia de su hijo
actualmente la violencia machista es la
primera causa de muerte violenta en
españa'
si no admitimos que tenemos un problema
con la violencia contra las mujeres es
imposible que encontremos una solución y
en periodismo si no somos capaces de
llamar a las cosas por su nombre es
imposible que como generadores de
opinión pública lleguemos a educar esa
conciencia social
vamos a la parte eco del ecofeminismo
en las noticias sobre medio ambiente la
falta de ética periodística no sólo se
ve en el titular es mucho más profunda y
tiene que ver con la comprensión misma
que tenemos por ejemplo del cambio
climático os lo voy a demostrar el
periodista jerarquiza la información y
lo hace lo hace en base a tres criterios
actualidad que esté pasando ahora
novedad que sea un hecho poco conocido
por el público y importancia que
dependerá del número de personas
afectadas de la notoriedad de la persona
implicada o de que sea un tema que está
de moda
apliquemos estos tres criterios al
cambio climático a ver qué pasa
actualidad si está pasando ahora pero es
que el cambio climático lleva pasando
más de 50 años con lo cual es imposible
mantener la tensión de la actualidad
durante tanto tiempo novedad si se
actualizan datos y estudios cada cierto
tiempo pero la realidad es que el cambio
climático avanza silenciosamente ante
nuestros ojos mientras no encontramos
excusa periodística para que abra un
informativo
importancia el que más pone en jaque
nuestra supervivencia sobre este planeta
implica a tanta gente que es tan difícil
de abarcar que al final se acaba
diluyendo
os dais cuenta como es un fenómeno que
pasa por encima de todos los criterios
periodísticos fijaos en esta noticia
europa más proclive a inundaciones en
sus ríos a causa del calentamiento
global
en qué sección colocaría esta noticia
podría estar en sociedad pero como habla
de europa también podríamos situarla en
internacional
bueno y también en economía porque al
fin y al cabo está hablando de los
recursos económicos de nuestro
continente
y por qué no el medio ambiente
pues porque no hay sección de medio
ambiente en la mayoría de periódicos
total que como no encaja en los
compartimentos estancos en los que se
organiza un medio de comunicación acá
vamos metiendo este tipo de noticias en
el cajón de sastre en este caso en la
sección de ciencia y tecnología que es
donde yo encontré esta noticia
al final las pocas informaciones que
podemos leer sobre cambio climático las
encontramos en lugares secundarios
dentro del medio y además están mal
enfocadas
en el caso de las inundaciones la causa
no es el calentamiento global ambos
fenómenos inundaciones y el aumento de
las temperaturas son consecuencia del
impacto de la actividad humana en el
planeta
es decir que las informaciones sobre
cambio climático suele poner el foco las
consecuencias inundaciones sequía
extinción de especies consecuencias
sobre las que por cierto nos sentimos
impotentes porque qué podemos hacer ante
una inundación nada y no suelen conectar
estos efectos con sus verdaderas causas
el consumismo y el sistema de producción
de nuestras sociedades occidentales
hadas
causas por cierto sobre las que si
podemos actuar
bien ante este panorama informativo en
el que mujeres y medioambiente son
invisibles o están maltratadas yo lo que
os propongo es que practiquemos otro
tipo de comunicación que visibilicen lo
invisible que conecte y que arroje luz
sobre el oculto una comunicación radical
que vaya a la raíz y nos permita
comprender los dos grandes retos de
nuestro tiempo el feminicidio y el
cambio climático os acordáis
interdependientes y eco dependientes
y diréis genial lo tengo claro pero yo
ni soy periodista ni tengo un medio de
comunicación y bueno ya me imagino que
no pero cuántas tenéis redes sociales o
un blog o habláis con otra gente todas
verdad pues si es que todas las personas
somos comunicadoras y todas tenemos una
responsabilidad así que vamos a ver en
qué consiste siguiendo el esquema de los
seis interrogantes del periodismo
clásico el que el quién cómo el cuándo
el dónde y el por qué empezamos con el
que que contamos mi sugerencia es que
cambies la mirada y os empecéis a fijar
en los márgenes para encontrar
protagonistas inesperadas historias de
personas que mejoran la vida de la gente
eso es lo que hizo joseba muruzábal
el artista empezó a fijarse en los
arcenes de las carreteras gallegas y se
dio cuenta que siempre veía una mujer en
mandilón llevando una carretilla con
sacos cosechando su huerta así que
decidió cubrir varios edificios con
enormes murales con abuelas con
superpoderes para precisamente
homenajear a las mujeres del mundo rural
esas mujeres invisibles que han dedicado
su vida a cuidar ya trabajar el campo
esta de la foto vuela a lo mary poppins
después de cosechar las verduras de su
huerta
y por cierto el arte urbano también es
una forma de comunicación
el segundo paso para practicar la
comunicación de los cuidados es
preguntarnos cómo como informamos esto
tiene que ver con la coherencia
comunicativa de nada vale tratar un
contenido que pone en el centro que
somos interdependientes y codependientes
si no nos preocupamos por el proceso de
elaboración mismo de esa información por
ejemplo darle voz a todas las partes
implicadas en una noticia vemos a diario
piezas informativas sobre inmigración
donde no oímos a personas migrantes o
noticias sobre empleo sin el testimonio
de personas con trabajos precarios dar
visibilidad a los protagonistas de las
noticias es completar el relato
y además cuidarlas durante el proceso
informativo respeto y empatía sin
interrogatorios para conseguir una
exclusiva y como comunicadoras
despojándonos de los estereotipos que
podamos tener instalados en la cabeza
he leído entrevistas a mujeres
maltratadas donde se las etiqueta de
víctimas y no de supervivientes y ese es
el hecho noticioso han sobrevivido
no solo estamos informando sino que
estamos construyendo el imaginario
alrededor de la vida de una persona y
eso puede empequeñecer la o empoderar la
y es mejor lo segundo
tercer interrogante quien decíamos todas
somos comunicadoras y eso significa que
tenemos que estar dispuestos a dialogar
y en un diálogo de saber a quién te
diriges verdad pues esa es otra forma de
cuidar hacer un esfuerzo por conocer a
tu interlocutor o interlocutor a para
hablarle en su idioma y sobre un tema
que le interese
la habláis igual a vuestro abuelo que a
una colega pues cuando nos dirigimos a
un público más amplio también tenemos
que ser capaces de adaptar el registro
si no nadie nos va a escuchar
cuarto interrogante donde ocurre esa
comunicación pues puede ocurrir en
distintos lugares y a través de
distintos medios cara a cara por
teléfono a través de internet
cuidar el medio significa tener en
cuenta la brecha digital sabéis que la
mitad de la población mundial no tiene
acceso a la red
y además tener en cuenta la huella
ecológica de la tecnología que usamos
porque internet no es inocuo
mandar correos electrónicos y mensajes
contamina y mucho pero bueno esto daría
para otra charla ted penúltimo
interrogante por qué
porque os cuento yo todo esto
bueno pues porque la información es
poder y estar bien informadas nos
permite actuar consciente y libremente
para defender lo nuestro nuestra vida
como lo hicieron las mujeres chicos las
amas de casa de los canal y las
pacifistas de granja en común
practicar la comunicación de los
cuidados es mi manera de mantener vivo
el espíritu de estas mujeres
yo creo que si potenciamos informaciones
protagonizadas por personas que quieren
cambiar el orden de las cosas
denunciamos la explotación de cualquier
ser vivo vegetal o animal y cuidamos la
manera de hacerlo con rigor y sin perder
la alegría
estaremos visibilizando aquello que es
invisible a nuestros ojos y esa en mi
opinión es la mejor manera de
transformar el mundo
a mí desde aquí me gustaría animaros a
que busquéis en los márgenes cuál es
vuestra manera de aplicar el
ecofeminismo
y yo me despido respondiendo al último
interrogante
cuando porque el momento es ahora muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]